"I am still in my kid.
Ask that it be that have to say I don't understand.
Called Grandpa, or I am going to say:
This guy is, because in space there are these gigantic birds, like terry battle.
That ended, and over that atmosphere,
except when they are state with a grey.
And that is why house are grey.
There are signs, a disease.
And I believe deep down in there,
these birds, that for leading the world in of the fact
the color of our sky...
and I...will be a failure."
Good morning, John.
That was a dramatic reading of YouTube's
auto-captioning of a video in which
you implore me
to teach your son about science,
because otherwise he'll ask you why the sky is blue
and you'll tell him the story about pterodactyl poop...
...or something.
One thing's very clear:
Google slash YouTube's auto-captioning,
right now, is very bad.
You can turn it on by clicking down here in the 'cc' button
and then sliding over.
And you could see how bad it is, auto-captioning
me right now.
Generally, right now, Google's auto-captioning
is 'Donald.  Report back with an elephant' bad.
But there's no denying that they're getting better at it
and Google, like it or not,
has in-depth analytical access to the
world's largest database of recorded, spoken words.
Which is YouTube.
Kinda strange to think of it that way, but
that is one of the things that YouTube is.
It also has a very deep well of talent;
very deep pockets
and strong economic incentives for being able to
figure out the words that are coming outta my mouth.
Go to find the lady that held the brotherhood's web servers.
If they could figure out what I'm talking about
they could run some ads down here,
and over here.
(ex') talking about exactly the stuff
that I'm talking about
This 'contextual ad' thing is how Google makes
all of its money, so they would like to
be able to do that with video.
They also want us to be able to talk into our phones,
which I can do right now
"Google is sometimes kind of creepy"
*beep*
Google is the first kind of creepy.
And that's pretty amazing.
But there are broader implications of this technology
that *wuaaah* kinda creep me out.
Unfortunately for Google, undertstanding
what words are being said and understanding
what those words mean, when strung
together into a sentence, they're
completely different tasks.
And one of them, which we're talking about right now,
is quite difficult.
But understanding the meaning of the sentence
turns out to be even harder.
Google has very strong economic incentives
to figure out what sentences mean,
and so far, they've been profoundly unable to do that.
Even with those deep pockets and all that talent
Google is completely unable to turn a sentence,
like the one I'm saying right now,
into useful information.
The software would be required to do far
too much analysis and synthesis of information
on its own.  And there's so much cultural context
that goes into all the stuff that we say,
and the tone of our voice.
If a program could actually understand
and synthesize data from these complex sentences,
that would pretty much be artificial intelligence.
I think that we dramatically underestimated
the complexity of our own brains.
And artificial intelligence would require us
to write the software that runs our brains,
and we have NO idea how our brains work.
But that does not mean that 100% accurate
speech recognition would not have
HUGE implications for the world.
If speech recognition were 100% accurate
for two different languages
subtitling conversations using handheld devices,
or even in-ear or in-eye devices,
would become trivial,
except that the translations would, of course,
be machine based.
And that's not entirely accurate, as anyone
who has used Google Translate can tell you,
but combining speech recognition
with an actual bionic implant, of a kind,
(which doesn't actually, to me, seem all that far off)
would, I think, have really dramatic implications
on what it means to be a person.  And anybody
who hasn't thought about that
should read this book.  It's called Feed.
So yes.  These funny little snippets of wrongly
translated text are funny.
They're cute, they're bad, and we talk
way too fast for them to understand us.
But that is just right now.  And if we know
anything about how technology works
it probably won't be too long before they
figure it out.
So it's probably very worth,
you and I, thinking about what that will mean...
...when it does work.
What it means, when Chinese cover president has heeded his advice from the beginning.
John, I'll see you on Wednesday.